the kind of reforms and incremental
Improvement that the current system is
capable of delivering are insufficient
so some form of radical reorganization
is required and I would say that to
focus primarily and where is power
coalescing is it observable are there
giant corporations that are wealthier
than Nations well that's an interesting
area to look at are there powerful
energy companies that are still being
offered subsidies that are still being
subsidized when there is an energy
crisis is there a military industrial
complex that's benefiting from what are
their pharmaceutical industries that are
benefiting from medical crisis right
these are all areas that you might want
to locate as potential problems so avert
your eyes for a moment from cultural
differences and focus on where power and
financial clout and the ability to
organize is currently centralized and
look at that that is the area what that
you that we collectively need to address
foreign
we're not doing a normal intro today I
think you might know this guy Russell
Brand welcome to the Reuben report here
in locals in Miami on your American tour
thanks for having me on the Reuben
report pretty good we got our own mugs
you can have that you want to keep that
mug yes please I'd like to sign it and
I'd like to I'll keep it as a Memento of
a already lovely occasion just arriving
here and meeting everyone it's been so
lovely you're bouncing all over the
place man it's been it's been a wacky
week do you have like a word that would
sum up what has happened since you got
to America the Bill Maher thing and then
you've done 800 shows and all over the
place what what word would sum it up for
you vicissitude like it's sort of like a
vacillating
undulating or shape-shifting state
altering kind of it's like it's been
it's interesting isn't it mate because
we're aware rather than the Vanguard of
the political conversation would you
want to be where where else would you
want to be but the truth is is that I
don't do well with antagonism I don't do
well with it I don't care for it much
you know I don't I prize Serenity very
highly I don't really particularly enjoy
being at the center of
uh uh of incendry matters nor do I enjoy
being criticized like say if you are
someone for feedback this is what I mean
you'll go oh have you got any feedback
do you know I actually mean can you give
me a series of very sincere and specific
compliments now that's what I mean I see
it's sincere and specific compliments
the way you did that was brilliant
thank you then I can sort of sit and
reflect on it as if I'm like with
studying something that's uh uh
objective and external I don't like to
feel attacked in particular perhaps
nobody does I long ago due to the nature
of celebrity have broadly elected to
extract myself from the discourse about
me uh deciding
as is suggested in my program uh what
other people think of me is none of my
business what other people think of me
it's none of my business you can do what
you want in your mind that's yours or
you could even say what you want it's
none of my it's none of my business it's
abstract but of course like on the level
of um how I actually feel I
um like all of us I'm sure a
well-intentioned person and I am
optimistic about human beings and I'm
I'm trying to do something that I feel
is important yeah and perhaps I hope I'm
doing it well but of course with no way
of knowing isn't it kind of funny like
someone that doesn't Court the
controversy and then you have a moment
like that real time which actually why
don't we just throw to it real quick
everyone's seen it a million times we'll
throw to it it's disingenuous to claim
that the biases they're exhibited on Fox
News are any different from the biases
exhibit on MSNBC it's difficult to
suggest but these corporations operate
as anything other than mouthpieces for
their affiliate owners in BlackRock and
Vanguard and unless we start to embrace
and it'll also mate like just
spiritually if I may use that word in
your great country we have to take
responsibility for our own perspective
I've been on that MSNBC mate it was
propagandist nuts crackery
Good morning Joe it was absurd the way
they came Good morning Joe yes I don't
know what it was it wasn't morning there
was no one called Joe there no one could
concentrate they didn't understand the
basic tennis of Journalism no one was
willing to stick up for genuine American
Heroes uh like Edward Snowden no one was
willing to talk about Julian Assange and
what he suffered trying to bring real
journalism to the American people and I
think to sit within the castle of MSNBC
throwing rocks have Fox News is
ludicrous make MSNBC better the moment
that you give me a specific example an
actual example okay
let me tell you what the specifically in
Europe I'd like to hear a specific
example approval specific example of an
MSNBC correspondent or anchor being on
television saying something they knew
was false and were saying behind the
scenes to his people this is I'm about
to go out and we know that we know that
the election wasn't stolen
example but I will go but I will go out
but I will go out on television and say
the opposite I will lie where's my
answer just give me up give me the
specific example give me a specific
example all right I'm with you I think
it's a false equivalency
it's not about bias it's a personal
thing because you don't actually know
anything about any of these
organizations you're talking about even
an MSNBC once big deal my
darling it was smaller than enough
do you want an example do you want an
example the ludicrous outrageous
criticisms of Joe Rogan around
Ivermectin who's deliberately referring
to his medicine
condemning Fox News without
acknowledging that you're participating
in the same game did you not just listen
to Bernie Sanders someone who plainly
legitimately believes in this country
and believes it's possible to change but
is bound by corruption is bound by the
lobbying system surely it's clear to you
Bill as one of the great pundits and
experts and comic voices for systemic
changes required money has to be taken
out of politics we need new political
systems that genuinely represent
ordinary Americans so that we can
overcome cultural differences and
bickering about which propagandist
network is the worst is not going to
save a single American life not improve
the life of a single American child not
going to approve America's standing in
the world and the world needs a strong
America I'll tell you that I'll tell you
that
it's an obligation a duty not to condemn
these people you weren't being a dick I
mean that's the thing you were trying to
say something very true something that
most of us are we know about media and
everything but then it gets turned into
like this destruction of this guy and
and I probably even feed into some of
that when I cover it on my show like man
that guy kind of deserved to get wrecked
but it wasn't it wasn't really about him
you weren't trying to make it about him
that was very clear I was astonished
anybody is willing to go to the map for
that set of values anymore but of course
I know that people are and yeah I don't
like the idea that I'm being polite to a
person and that's not in accordance with
my values but you weren't really being
impolite you you were being passionate
right like you were you weren't rude to
him I don't think I think you were you
were confident in what you were saying
and it needed to be said yeah I feel we
can't move forward with the conversation
from like it happens in politics doesn't
it you know when they say oh well this
is only happening this is the last
Administration done that this is because
CNN or Fox News or whatever just like
well why don't we focus on what we're
contributing individually or if we claim
to be the representative of some sort of
movement class culture or advocacy group
perhaps then we can look at how if we
claim to speak on behalf of them and
certainly I make no such claim then we
should look after ourselves and our own
conduct and because as Gandhi said I
find I am such a sinner in my own life
I'm not confident when it comes to
judging others I try to monitor my own
behavior but I am engaged in punditry I
am engaged in commentary so you know
like and as as I said I suppose in that
conversation it's not like I
particularly aligned with Fox News as an
institution in fact I have a rather
colorful history with that organization
right right so when you were preparing
for the show or they're telling you you
know they do obviously they do a
pre-interview with you or you pass that
point uh we kept trying to do it but I
kept not doing it so I kept not doing
the praying right you knew what the
topics were going to be right
no I knew like uh what happened they
said that they were gonna they said that
that might come up actually they said I
thought that they said we would talk
about the pandemic and then I think that
they said that there was a possibility
that the changing nature of the
relationship between Fox News and Trump
would come up
and and so I suppose it was within the
orbit of that topic that the Contra
tongue around the distinctions between a
neo-liberal establishment media and
neoconservative establishment media was
discussed yeah it was so interesting
because when he was trying to get you I
give you the one right like he was
trying to give me give me one time that
they intentionally lied and it's like
man we could do this all day very fine
people on both sides Brett Kavanaugh is
a serial rapist the Covington kids are
racist I mean I do this on my show every
day you went with the Rogan one and it's
like he just didn't have much after he
wanted to but does it get to that point
of like it's weird that anyone defends
it is that really what you think this is
about I'm starting to come to that too
that it's hard to defend at this point
I've this is where I'm at Dave
I'm at why don't we now acknowledge that
there are different ways of being a
human and call a kind of truce and
accept that there are some people for
this for the sake of Simplicity that
there are progressive ways of being a
human being there are traditional ways
of being a human being neither of those
ways are wrong why don't we allow one
another to express ourselves how we want
to within the obvious bounds of consent
and then perhaps we can organize
different alliances so that we can
organize around the systems of
centralized power that will else wise
continue to dominate and annihilate do
you sense that that's happening right
now I mean me living here in Florida I
mean look you know I'm gay I'm married I
have two kids like this is the Freedom
Place you know they make it seem like
it's the place of right-wing crazy
people and everything I'm freaking loved
here and I and I love it right back it's
wild
it was freaking Halloween we took our
kids in strollers met every neighbor
within 10 square blocks everybody not
one weird comment side nobody cares
nobody that's what's happening right
here I think what you're what you're
calling for yeah but it's not happening
everywhere do you feel that that would
um be able to escalate through the
various expressions of like every letter
of the lgbtq plus Monica I mean I
personally have nothing to do with that
whole thing like I happen to be gay and
I'm married to a guy and and that's it I
only represent myself as I think you
probably only represent Russell Brand so
when they try to put it right who else
if Russell Brand I represent but there
are parts of that guy that were nothing
to do with who who's the true
representation of Russell and where are
so many of us goodbye Ruby Tuesday who
could put a name on you when you change
with every new day there you go
um yeah I I don't know that
well let's put it this way if if there
was a trans person walking around the
the town I don't think they would be
ridiculed or anything I think people
basically are just kind of Live and Let
Live politics is making us all kind of
nuts at this point politics and the
culture and and I can't I cannot see it
anymore is inadvertent it feels to me
that it must be a requirement of
sustaining the systems of power that
benefit for example in the pandemic in
the obvious observable and trackable
ways financially and through the ability
to surveil and introduce new regulation
these they must benefit from ongoing
conflict so it's a needed piece of the
puzzle so to me like it yeah it is
actually and so my sense is that instead
like there cannot be one homogenized
version of this is you know there cannot
be a uniculture there cannot be a
unipolar world so you cannot have a new
hegemonic there must be be the
acceptance of I would say sort of a
compatible
interconnected
localized systems of governance that the
as much Freedom as much democracy as
much community and the systems have my
sense is and again it's just a vague one
the systems of aggregation benefit
people at the top of them from
agriculture through industrialization
through technology whilst there are
obvious benefits to agriculture to a
population at large the most significant
gains are experienced at the top of
those systems and the Amendments that
are possible are not made like
industrialization and even the sort of
like the the so-called white goods
revolution in this country in the 1950s
you're going to have plenty of time with
your new dishwasher and it's like do we
have any more time how's the technique
are there different ways of deploying
these sets of tools or is everything
subtly and unconsciously being used in
the service of a particular idea that's
is oddly centralizing yeah Peter Thiel
always says you know they promised us
flying cars and we got 140 characters
you know in essence we've sort of
stopped innovating now and we're just
Doom scrolling all day long remember
remember back in our day when the
internet stopped you'd go to a page and
it would stop at the bottom oh yeah
remember that and then they got rid of
that so you just scroll forever and it
never stops and you're looking for more
more craziness yes it's nihilistic I
kind of sense that you're you're more
libertarian than anything else even
though people are always like he's a the
people on the right are always like he's
a lefty but I like him something like
that that's that's what they do let's
see you're kind of like
that's there could be a movie in that
they said that but but I sense you're
mostly like you're you're talking about
decentralization you're talking about
local communities you're you're talking
about taking power away and that kind of
stuff like you're mostly just Live and
Let Live I mean the show is stay free
right like yes I suppose when people
talk about libertarianism sometimes
there's the so is that the suggestion
that we uh do not have a duty and
obligation to love and care for one
another I suppose I don't feel that that
needs to be mandated by uh at the end of
a gun right that people can love one
another consensually and that we can
organize in various different publics we
can have the maximum amount of democracy
that we can honor the highest aspects of
our nature that broadly speaking I would
respond sympathetically to a person
suffering if I could see them what I'm
beginning to feel is that we have become
uh this joint it that we have there's
been an aberration from the conditions
of our origin there's nothing in our
Evolution that suggests that we would be
able to live in societies of 300 million
people let alone 7 billion people whilst
that is part of the reality that we're
on a rock in Infinite Space we are also
in communities and I like that phrase
that I think I heard from Helena Norberg
Hodge uh act local think Global so like
we can have as much democracy in our
community as possible that we allow
people to organize their communities
however they want to unless it has a
negative impact on another Community or
the individuals within that Community
are not happy with it and that we have
to accept that there are many different
ways of Being Human traditional ways new
and emergent ways new roles new
identities allow people to be who they
are allow people to have as much
democracy in their schools as much
democracy in there in there even Law and
Order or be Democratic in my country for
example I heard like I respect very much
people that are working Services because
I understand the value of sacrifice and
I have friends that will work in the
police will thank God and like I I feel
that wouldn't it be good if the forces
of uh you know even law enforcement is a
phrase that we've got some that are you
know as a true an anarchist libertarian
that I have some issues with because who
do you mandate to you know because the
relationship between sovereignty and the
governed is traditionally being you give
us taxis we won't get you won't let you
get killed by Bandits or whatever but
maybe that'll be the basics of it yeah
you know those Bandits they could get
you at any time give and show me your
money and we'll protect you from it but
what I feel Dave is that uh it would be
nice if there were consensual policing
consensual governance you live in the
area like it's a sort of localism like
this phrase they're I suppose do have
like particular phrases and ideas that
have sort of stayed in the sphere of
your awareness for a long while and they
start to become part of your personal
philosophy in my case when Gandhi said
at the point of Indian independence this
is a country of 70 000 Villages each one
should be fully independent trading only
when necessary running and governing
themselves there's no point in US
kicking out the British then replicating
the very institutions that they
installed and it seems that we are doing
this now globally sets of
institutionalized power whether they're
corporate or state that don't allow
Ordinary People to have very much
Freedom it's interesting because you're
you're basically I think selling me from
an American perspective you're selling
federalism I mean the idea that the
states should basically do everything
locally and that we should have some
structure above that but it should
probably be way weaker than this crazy
structure that nobody believes in now
that is completely ineffective and
probably very authoritarian oh if that's
the way that you turn it then yeah so
federalism the idea that the states
basically I'm as a Floridian
everything that goes on with my life
should have to do with Florida and the
laws of Florida the U.S government the
federal government should have basically
nothing to do with me except guard the
borders and you know a couple that make
sure the states aren't at War a couple
other things like that yeah leave
everyone alone I suppose you're nice for
you guys to have that in the UK huh what
about I suppose look the point of the
state is obviously supposed to be in
order to prevent external attack
military I mean or gargantuan
corporatism you one needs a state that
can support the collective will of the
people that elected them now given that
the for some time and this would include
both in my view both administrations
both political parties that they're so
damn near to equal that to quarrel about
which one is superior would be I would
consider literally a waste of time even
now after covert because that because I
would agree with you for for most I
think we're roughly the same age for
most of our Lives yeah but I think
something shifted in kovid where it's
very very clear like the Republicans
they ain't great but like they're much
less the Democrats we ain't great but
you get this Health Care oh yeah we
ain't great but we were bearing covered
but we ain't great off
off then yeah we stayed open here
it's why I moved here right that's
something that's something sure thanks
for something yeah thanks you know like
that's that that's I can't get hard for
that conversation yeah for like oh is it
a bit better right and that really was
the point with when you were doing the
Fox News MSN yeah but that is the point
that was the same point yeah yeah it's
like let's do better like because also
like you know if I always feel like I'm
on the presser piece of the Pinker
conversation of do you know that so many
people have been pulled out of poverty
and things are so great now oh really I
must be imagining all this terrible
misery that I'm seeing everywhere all of
this Despair and nihilism and
Desperation I must be imagining it I
must be imagining a spiritual void at
the very core of our culture because
I've Just Seen now that you've told me
that there's never been as good I know
like you know I respect uh Professor
Jordan throughout history people you
know that but for me that's
apology that's not bold enough people
this is it the old idea is dead the new
ideas must emerge it's going to require
new alliances it's going to require new
conversations if we are unwilling to
have them we are going to experience new
forms of authoritarianism and
centralization it's already happening
both political parties have been
co-opted by the same corporate forces
they will behave in the same way now I
know that in my understanding is that
you have um you know like that you
understand is that you're let down with
Ron DeSantis and I don't know very much
about him except I feel like I read like
about that uh and like giving good deal
in the lever the other day giving good
deals to the energy folks and
subsidizing things you know like I don't
feel like anybody that's operating
within that system is capable of
genuinely representing the will of the
people and I'm not saying like the
Rhonda Sanders is particularly bad but
no and I know he's super popular here
and let people love him I would say he's
particularly good here I know he's in
aberration but I get your your broader
point is that if you're still operating
within the system that has the system
itself that is
so I fully accept that yeah and also I
don't think I don't think any
politicians whether it's DeSantis or if
you brought back George Washington I
don't think they're Gods they're just
people right right yeah so he's
operating within a system I would say
he's he's the best that we can get out
of this system and has he's done an
awful lot here like I guess there's no
crime we have no basically you know no
homeless people we have uh you know we
stayed open we don't mandate backs like
all the stuff sounds great but you know
that there would be people from the
other like you know John Oliver yeah
he's writing staff we're watching you
now yeah they would be saying uh excuse
me wouldn't they and they would in
particularly be talking about that
Library stuff and the school stuff and I
watched these items the other day about
they but in some schools they've banned
that Two Dads of a penguin thing no I
mean the only thing they they did a
thing on it today like this is where
John Oliver to me just like fails
miserably like he's making up most of
that stuff the book they've banned
basically two books one of them was
about what was it called guys we always
go queer Theory where they were
literally it was going to teach like
third graders how to give hand jobs
literally well that penguin one what
about yeah
what's that genderqueer but I don't
think the penguin you're talking about
the Penguin's the two that's right right
so they are reviewing a few things
obviously and also on the journal but
look I'm not you know I mean I'm just
saying like yeah I don't need to make if
I don't give you the uh counter argument
sure it's the point in having me here
like what it seemed to me that they were
saying is that that legislation given
that it was drafted by a lawyer
obviously has like a sort of a looseness
in it that means that it could be
applied in ways that would not be
particularly persmissive permissive
excuse me or evolved when it comes to
for example being able to have
conversations with even like a 17 year
old around sort of sexuality and I like
feel that something like you know like
and again I'm basing this on just a
YouTube video
like but it seems just for the record it
was for K through third grade not 17
year olds they said it could be applied
because it's not specific to the
language because it would Cooperative
parental consent is it like there's the
weather point that you're you know I'm
just passing on all of this research
here because you know I don't know
um but like um but for me it would seem
that that you know that I only showed
videos of this sort of testimony that
was leading to the success of this I
guess it maybe it's in particular
districts or particular schools you'll
have to tell me when you watch you're so
much more qualified in so many ways but
it appeared to me to be that that's the
side of things where I would fall down
the site I would want kids that are gay
to know that it's all right to be gay
right well of course I would want that
but I my personal belief is it has
nothing to do with the public schools so
that might be where you and I have a
little bit of a disagreement which I'm
completely fine with by the way but the
I mean think about how old are you do
you say how old you are you is that no I
know are you as a I'm a nine-year-old
little lad I'm from Finland
why don't you ask me that why would you
say that I'm feeling so self-conscious
about it what if I die then what am I
going to do no I get your point about
public schools as well I just don't
think a state employee should be talking
to someone else's kid about sex it's as
simple as that these like that's my
basis but obviously the argument the
counter argument Dave is that the
Assumption of heterosexual like that in
a way heterosexuality is the norm is
being presented to them it's not like
you're talking about sex you're talking
about relationships because that Penguin
book ain't talking about sex is talking
about sort of loving relationships so
anyway so I'm just but I I also agree
because when it comes to my children I
don't want my children well that's it
that's it right it's funny that I'm
coming because you are a gay man who's
married to a man and you've got children
sir I'll tell you a thing or two about
being a gay man tell me about these
penguins well okay you know you don't
know much about it like but what I want
to say is that I don't like people
telling what to do at all right at all
on anything I just want to be left alone
I just want to be left alone and I would
like to form communities on the basis of
consent and people wanting to be in that
community and then through bloody tiring
exhausting boring democracy decide how
that Community has evolved at the
maximum level of control and when it's
handed over it's always handed over
consensually and in a way that's
understood we're gonna like say oh I
can't be bothered to work out around the
sewage plant you do it well I
can't remember but when I find out that
the water is owned by Foreign interests
and they're dumping into our Rivers
which is happening in our country
because the water authorities have been
sold off when they privatized everything
yeah I'm not suggesting re-nationalize
Community owned their assets Community
decide whether or not they want sewage
jumped in their Rivers maximum amount of
democracy maximum amount of respect for
the environment maximum amount of
respect that's what we aspire to and it
seems that across the Earth they love it
that's what I am you're a federalist
maximum amount democracy no you don't
want labels but I mean you believe in
local control and and people making
decisions for themselves with some
limited structure yeah some limits and
always being aware that of the tendency
to rampant corporatism because at the
moment that is what's happening and when
people are claiming localism they're
sort of turning a blind eye to the way
that corporatism can exploit that
localism if not properly undertaken that
if there's any Alliance at all is in
order to confront gargantuan corporate
power so as you've been on this and get
money out of politics altogether should
we offer that in yeah isn't it funny
though that was a big thing 20 years ago
like and when it's just gone it's just
remember that so the politicians decided
hold on a minute let's leave the money
in politics Somebody's gotta pay for
these states you know you ever go out to
dinner in DC these people are eating
well are they yeah of course they are
have you ever been to any of the like
the big globalist things you ever known
I've never been invited to any of those
because sometimes for some reason they
bring in celebs they might have picked
up that but maybe before you were like
fully you know yeah no never actually
maybe if I can't remember I can't
remember ever going anywhere and
thinking this is reprehensible what was
the moment that you got sort of into
this the politics side of this thing I
know it's not you're not really
political in a way but you clearly are
talking about politics but was that I
mean you're an actor in a comic like was
that kind of always in you or was there
like a moment that had happened did
kovid kind of escalate it that's a comic
that's a type of a job isn't it like
like a comedian actually for me is a
sort of Beyond a job that's a religion
yeah that's a purpose it's a perspective
actor is a type of a job for me uh the
the the or My World Views is part of my
condition is part of where I come from
it's part of what I believe in and the
becoming an actor that's just simply
just opportunism I was doing stand-up
comedy I got jobs on the TV as a result
of that I then got off of movies all of
these things oh these are all
interesting exciting things and by God
were they exciting and for for a while
but my actual what would we be like if
it look I sometimes like this if it
didn't exist would I invent it if it
didn't like you know if there was no
such thing as a movie industry would I
go why don't we spend like a hundred
million dollars telling this story and
what we'll do is we'll get to trailers
at four o'clock in the morning I'll stay
in there most of the time then I'll pop
out for a bit and like do some a little
bit of acting no what I want to do is
communicate truthfully and connect
people if anything it's like a kind of
secular and inclusive evangelism that's
deeply devout and accepting of the
different ways that people might find
God that each of us are going to have
our own journey to God that doesn't mean
that people might not be part of a
religious community or indeed a global
Faith but that if we do not have a
connection to something that I would
call some sublime or Divine that we are
likely to become lost in materialism
individualism nihilism and progressivism
and by progressivism I don't mean
cultural progressivism the idea that
human beings are on this journey to
better and better stuff and that doesn't
seem to be happening other than I would
say through the false markers of
medicine technology and although they
are marvelous great Miracles is that
what you're up to more than anything
else that we're just like in this lack
of truth right now and even to bring it
back to the real-time moment like you
were trying to say something true in a
cultural world where nothing is true
right like you do your show every day
you talk about politics and it's like a
lot of it is just debunking
right like the people that just shovel
all day long yes that's what
that is what I'm trying to do I'm trying
to
um what I feel like mate is that I'm
limited in my understanding of most
things in fact the sum total of all
human knowledge is negligible compared
to their vast limitlessness of all
potential realities so there has to be a
kind of blunt pregnant pragmatism to the
way that we organize culture and society
and the only reference that that I can
access is how did we evolve did we
evolve to live in giant communities I
can see that there are ways where living
like having broad alliances would be
hugely beneficial I can see that there
are ways where the Miracles of
technology and medicine and science are
hugely hugely applicable obviously of
course I live in the world but it seems
that there is an invisible ideology that
doesn't declare and state itself
explicitly and all of their even
apparent cultural arguments happen take
place within its framework and what I
would call it is commodification
consumerism late capitalism corporatism
Global corporatism neoliberalism that
this ideology isn't being openly
discussed and it's at its nadir it's
dying it's already dead it died in 2008
and now we've got something bizarre and
monstrous so we have like a Frankenstein
trying to keep it together or something
while they were rearranging chairs on
the Titanic as they're sinking something
like that yes that's what I feel like
yes that's what I feel like and I feel
like if it is not
succinctly and explicitly addressed
we're going to experience new types of
authoritarianism that frame themselves
in albeit apparently novel ways that
benefit hugely from arguing about the
sort of stuff like even you know the
stuff about like the public schools or
whatever when plainly like that if you
said I want to raise my kids in this way
I'd go oh okay let me know I know and I
would assume that you would be the same
with me like who cares like as long as
it's not you know we'll know what a sort
of abuse there will seem to be some
Universal ideas that we understand when
you're when you're traveling do you see
places that it's working better than
other places I mean now you've been a
couple days in Florida but you were just
in Cali where it's obviously way
different I did a stand-up show in
Clearwater yeah and I really liked it
and what I do recognize yes and I do
recognize that there's a sort of a deep
sense of sort of like Pride here and
that obviously somewhat due to the
stance that Florida took during the
lockdown the
anti-orthoritarianism is being expressed
you know like that the governor is the
anti-government figure in in your state
but uh and and you know why not I'm not
pessimistic about human beings generally
speaking but like I would always just
look at where is the funding coming from
what's the ultimate intention what kind
of alliances I would just ask the same
questions that I'd ask of anybody is it
as Democratic as possible and I'm like
you know and the it's better than I
would always reject because from both
sides as we've said that's what I was
sort of rejecting on the tele program
the other day and I'm I don't know run
the scientists through all I know he
could be Jesus but like you know like
sort of like I'm pretty sure he's 19.
but maybe I can get you guys to sit down
for coffee yeah God absolutely you know
I'd like that I'd like that what I do
accept is that
what that Dave is that I I feel that we
want the maximum amount of authority in
our own lives Max like personal
Authority and autonomy excuse me and the
maximum amount of democracy and like I
told you at the beginning of this
conversation I don't really like
controversy and I don't think that any
of that stuff's even particularly
complicated I'm just sort of inviting
people that identify on the right to be
as Discerning as I would invite people
that identify on the left to be like who
are we definitely operating on behalf of
Ordinary People totally inclusive
non-judgmental completely loving not
secretly operated on behalf of economic
interests in some you know is one of
those directions easier than the other
like right now obviously people are on
the right dig here and that's I think
probably a little weird for you in some
respects right like people that maybe a
couple years ago you thought ah these
weren't yeah my people but they're
that's what I found you know I was a
lefty my whole life and then suddenly I
started saying a few things about
Freedom kind of what you're preaching
here in a probably more simplistic way
and next thing I knew all these people
that that I thought were the bad guys
were like hey you want to have dinner
let's see what's what
but what we'll say I like how you switch
mugs like like that
what was in there I have no idea what's
in there I know so it's gone from Blue
to Red yeah yeah
um because in a way it doesn't matter
they're both basically the same
effective right
um but because
there's still statistics on where the
funding comes from on the number of
people in Congress that own stocks and
chairs in like energy companies or the
military industrial complex it's just
basically the same it's just basically
the same so that's the sort of my
position certainly I've found that
people
uh like that I identify as being sort of
conservative or republican or whatever
have been very open to this conversation
and look I it's clear to me
and a matter of record that about 30 40
years ago or maybe even earlier than
that the liberal establishment became
co-opted by the same Financial interests
that have traditionally been associated
with right-wing politics if you look at
the conditions that led to the war in
Iraq and the kind of relationships and
the kind of re restructuring that took
place in that country and the
catastrophe that happened around that
war that was Cheney and Bush and now
look at what's happening elsewhere and
there are sort of I would say comparable
conversations that could take place and
it's pretty clear where like the sort of
Clinton Foundation gets money from and
the way that they advocate for
particular things so what I feel like is
and is that the solution will not come
from within that system I don't want to
Glory it by reveling in the differences
because actually where I am from is a
normal modest blue-collar working class
background in Essex England and when I
see people demonized on the basis of of
their class or their culture whether
they are in the dominant cultural group
sexually or racially or culturally or a
smaller a cultural group you know by
those markers if economically we are
attacking people if we're attacking a
class that is economically dispossessed
then I feel like oh I see what's
happening now I see what's happening I
see why people are angry I see why
people feel that they're being spoken
down to they are being spoken down to
and I suppose
Dave that that's the thing that I felt
wasn't being addressed and isn't being
addressed that the blame is being put on
people that aren't empowered and also
that there's an escalation of okay no
the the the the kind of accusations
around uh God what am I gonna say
perjuring people's beliefs oh those
people are just racist those people are
just this or just that and I I I'm
actually generally quite optimistic
about people and think that people will
get along if you leave them alone and if
you don't impecuniate them and
impoverish them do you think a whole
bunch of people are just going to kind
of check out of the system because I
think a lot of people intuitively get
what you're saying and they really do
want to Live and Let Live thing I think
there really is a feeling of that in
America right now that the whole system
is so screwed up it's so wacky it's not
in it for anyone except you know the few
that control it I think a lot of people
are just going to be like all right I'm
just checking out I'm deleting the
accounts I'm figuring out how to get off
the grid you know and just really just
kind of Disappearing I I think it's
probably happening as we speak I wonder
about that movement I wonder about a
sort of a second kind of Declaration of
Independence like what would happen if
people did that our community we are no
longer associating with the
superstructure we want our own new
Confederacy have you heard of that from
from you know in America they're talking
about it now Texas there's some
congressmen that put took forward a bill
to have a secession and get out just get
out of the union and you know maybe some
of the red States could move out and you
know something like that it seems like
you know we're United but what are we
United by it's hard I wonder yeah I
guess that's a conversation that needs
to carry on it needn't be presented as
adversarial right that's because it
comes off as adversarial but it
shouldn't it well it's an I believe in
diva in our country
which is obviously an absurd term
because the country is a concept what is
it really a flag a set of beliefs of
group of people if it isn't benefiting
those people what is it doing that land
mass across the pond you see that thing
you know this language you're using like
like the Devolution was a big
conversation like you know a few years
ago and Scottish independence is
discussed and Wales has an assembly and
obviously because of the colonization
and imperialism in Era and the north of
that country these so and because
Britain is an imperial and colonial
power historically these conversations
have been ongoing and I feel like if
these institutions do not exist for the
benefit of the people that they claim to
serve what is it that they are doing and
I think you can make that that's that's
the type of inquiry that I don't claim
to have the answer to or the conclusions
to but I feel that that ought be the
investigation that takes place and it
won't be disingenuous and it won't be a
sort of Sly way of masking corporatism
or allowing people to avoid this or
evade that or benefit from this or you
should do what the the term that keeps
occurring to me is satra's good faith
let's have good faith conversations oh
look we're different from one another
how do you want to organize this how do
you think that people best can behave
collegiately what's the sort of critical
mass before this gets a little
complicated because the tendency appears
to be economically LED globalism
currently becoming instituted in an
attempt to create a unipolar hegemony
through various means and an inability
to accept that there are a variety of
cultures that sort of are independently
vying for their right to exist you ever
worry we're in that dystopian future
already like we're too deep in it to the
point where we don't even know where
exactly you know skynet's basically been
turned on the machine is operating and
we're kind of all in the Matrix we have
these little glimmers I kind of think
it's why your clip on Real Time took off
it was like a little glimmer of Truth
amongst all of the lies and we see it
and then it and then we all get lost in
the BS again and then you wait for
another glimmer but you sort of just
never get out of the the Slumber or
something like that yeah I do feel that
but I also deeply believe in the
possibility of Awakening and what I
haven't mentioned yet because I guess
you know I tend to communicate in
accordance with the context that I find
myself in is that most of what I believe
in is undergirded by spiritual beliefs
rather than political ones yeah don't
actually you know all I know politically
is just sort of just the conversational
Layman's knowledge like that's you know
I mean I've not been through higher
education I've not been to University I
don't claim to know any more than
anybody that's just watching this now
but that's why your politics is
interesting because it doesn't come from
politics it's obviously coming from
something else that's why I think it's
it's hitting you know it comes from a
sense of like that as human beings we
know that we need meaning and purpose we
know that we have this sort of yearning
for freedom freedom expression freedom
to be who we really are we also know
that there are Myriad ways of Being
Human and that there seems to be some
scarce remembered time where we could
live differently there seems to be an
awareness that we are not at the Apex
but we are at the end of something that
we could go this could go either way
that we could yield to more centralizing
authoritarianism or we could look at
different models that the there may be
information in the past deep deep in the
past Arcane anthropological information
there may be even in the genius of
Thomas Paine and the your founding
fathers and all that stuff that's of
real value but certainly there needs to
be some new principles enacted and I
think that even to move forward or into
that territory we might have to offer
one another the grace of this a certain
amount of discordance so what do you do
if a certain amount of people don't want
to offer that Grace because again I'm
with you and I think I think a lot of
people watch it
you have to take camps I assume right
like you got it no but what do you do if
you know if you sit down with the you
know if Florida was like Hey you know
we've just kind of had enough no offense
we're just gonna do our thing and take
care of our people it's gonna be very
pleasant here yeah you know let
everybody live as free as they want but
if the other guys just keep saying no no
no no no no no no we still want some of
that we want some of the cash we want
some of the goodness we want you know
what do you do then I suppose then
Florida would because I think a lot of
people are thinking about I think the
Ordinary People of each of the states
would have to it has been long argued
typically I would have to say from the
left that the ordinary people of the
world have more in common with one
another than they have with the elites
that govern
and that this has the potential of being
communicated now through the Miracles
that we are currently enjoying
in his book The Revolt of the public
Martin Guri the former CIA analyst you
should have on your show if you haven't
already yeah he's good man he says that
the just the technology the medium you
know in a Malcolm uh what am I trying to
say uh Malcolm the medium is the message
yeah yeah yeah like that
that what we are experiencing now is the
ability to communicate to dissent in new
ways that power is organizing
differently that you can't centralize
and control in the same way so new forms
of authoritarianism are emerging the
possibility and we've already seen
through Napster in the Arab Spring and
occupy the potential for organization
almost spontaneously
but I would say that
these are the conversations I'm having
now and the reason I'm having them is
that if they're like why even oh you
could even reject the term Florida who
could reject the term New York you could
although you could decide how like I
would say the max amount of democracy it
needs to be as local as possible as
local as possible as little centralized
Authority as possible
but there obviously needs to be a degree
of organization I would say that if that
I would say well if the price of people
of Florida being left alone is the
people of California being left alone if
you want to use those geographical or
pre-existing States and that kind of
terminology I'm just trying to bring us
down to something on Earth I got what
you're doing at the yeah that physical
level yeah yeah but as much democracy as
possible as much democracy as possible I
suppose and again this is not going to
be immediately perfect but which Which
social system ever has arrived fully
formed and also we're not aiming
entirely for Perfection we're aiming for
improvement and and the kind of reforms
and incremental Improvement that the
current system is capable of delivering
are insufficient so uh some form of
radical reorganization is required and I
would say that to focus primarily on
where is power coalescing is it
observable are there giant corporations
that are wealthier than Nations well
that's an interesting area to look at
are there powerful energy come companies
that are still being offered subsidies
that are still being subsidized when
there is an energy crisis is there a
military industrial complex that's
benefiting from what are their
pharmaceutical industries that are
benefiting from medical crisis right
these are all areas that you might want
to locate as potential problems so avert
your eyes for a moment from cultural
differences and focus on where power and
financial clout and the ability to
organize is currently centralized and
look at that that is the area what that
you that we collectively need to address
this isn't the most comfortable question
but do you ever get nervous that you're
you're hitting close to something oh no
right and do you get nervous about just
your life like you don't have to do this
you can check out and disappear and you
know you can meditate and do all and
jump in the ice bath and do all the
stuff that you want to do forever but
you're you're hitting close to something
and that that comes with risks
however however you want to well then
you think oh we're not all doing the
same thing you're not doing it no I do
think we are doing it yeah you're in
there as well yeah and I do think about
it and I think about it now more than
ever because now I have two young kids
where before you know it was just me and
one guy now I got other issues other
people to take care of
or do you just not think about it
because you're just doing it and that's
it well I sometimes I think about stuff
like that but
I really believe in some things I really
you can't stop that's what my answer is
I can't stop but I'm quite applaud and
like and also I'm pretty you know I
could be pretty selfish as well I mean
like you know I mean I'm personally
recovery that's what I am really is a
person in recovery like so I'm I'm aware
of my frailties I'm aware of that and in
a way isn't it that yeah I don't try not
to um augment self-fetishization because
I generate enough of that in-house you
know like I find it pretty easy to get
sort of excited about myself so I try to
focus on can you be of any use to other
people and like I'm aware of looking
this conversation people no run this out
this is absolutely amazing and like
maybe he is I don't know you live in
Florida you're friends with him you know
more than me I'm just like all I'm
asking is where is there are the what
are the interests what are people
benefiting and the answer like when I
did that show in Clearwater people were
happy man yeah you know they were happy
but I told some terrific jokes so I've
got to take some of the credit for that
you know like how many terrific jokes
you get which are actually ones that are
deliverable conversationally probably
zero like my jokes are long long but
there's a laugh every 20 seconds it's
good gear you would have a good time you
and your husband maybe don't bring the
kids but like you know like it would be
they don't speak English yet we'll be
all right no way well they don't speak
any other babies they're babies yeah I
thought that he was raising them to
speak Polish yeah they're all these
people this is a good move I like it
polish-speaking children why not
it's doing stand up like is that you at
your best like is that late yeah you're
just like pure joy like because that's
what I've always said is that people can
see like it's easy like look
I know like safely for the thing would
be to wear a bill Mark they'll extract a
bit of it they'll go oh Russell Brand
histrionic breakdown and they won't go
but look at he spoke about uh Bernie
like it's like look Bernie Sanders is
trying his best he's talking about
centralized Authority I know you don't
you're not down with Bernie Sanders but
like you know I think he's a person you
were I think explaining Bernie's
positions better than Bernie that was
the funny thing because when they asked
when Bill asked him about Equity
inequality he completely had no answers
infuriated we knew that in it yeah you
hate people not to know the difference
between yeah like how do you say to
the Socialist do you know the difference
between socialism and capitalism and he
had no idea like that in essence was
what happened but you tried to kind of
help him a little bit in a way you were
a better argument you were a better
Communicator of his ideas I think than
he is which My Hope Is that Bernie
Sanders is a person that is genuinely
interested in decentralizing power and
attacking corporatism and standing up
for ordinary Americans because if that
isn't what you're doing then there isn't
anything else to do in politics there
isn't any other job in politics except
representing the interests of Ordinary
People service love devotion like oh no
financial institutions have got too much
power oh no there's too much lobbying
money oh no this two-pie system isn't
working if you're not doing that so I
have to approach people with good faith
so like I guess I should say yeah let's
approach Rhonda santis and Bernie
Sanders and Donald Trump and Elizabeth
Warren let's look at them let's assume
they're doing their best and let's see
what the results are if the results are
those people are individually very
wealthy and Ordinary People are homeless
and this they all get very well I know
isn't that weird they all get very rich
while doing this isn't it bizarre how
did Obama get uh he's got like a 30
million dollar house in Martha's
Vineyard on the water isn't that bizarre
it's unfortunate that but it's
unfortunate that people tend to end up
accumulating money but I mean being paid
also yeah but also I don't run a
political party you're not just saying I
don't think there should be any you
don't just send back the cash you'll
keep that you keep that I'm just happy
to sit in front of the sign and chat
with people you don't feel and I don't
sense you feel any guilt about that a
lot of people feel guilt about their
success and you care about other people
but I don't sense you're guilty in a way
that you know like a lot of the lefties
of Hollywood would be like oh you know
on one hand they'll be super wealthy and
live you know in the nicest house in Bel
Air and on the other hand they'll
pretend that they're guilty about it
when it clearly isn't lined up with
their life well sometimes I do feel a
bit guilty actually a little bit I mean
I wish that everybody lived really
really well but I as I say I come from a
pretty normal background and for a while
I was a drug addict and I've lived on
welfare for a significant portion of my
life in a few years when I'm signing on
that's what you call it in England and
so I do a bit think oh God is this right
but then like because also it's for me
the grandiosity but I earned this on
Merit I do recognize eyes that there are
you know that there are certain Revenue
generating skill sets in the culture
that rewards for example comedy or
football or legal expertise I recognize
how these things happen and I also don't
think that moderate affluence is the
real problem I think it's called
gigantism so like uh like so I try not
to again be too self-flagellating about
it because that's a form of vanity as
well right and for as much as you may
have some cool stuff and do your thing
I've got this now this jumper I have a
lovely sweater and that necklace must
have been I can only imagine 80s I've
had this ages
but the point is that your level of
wealth is not the wealth that you're
talking about that's pulling the strings
of the machine and all that stuff it
would be the amount I have it would be
the exact time you're right there you're
right at the precipice after that the
bad guys there's going to be some real
redistribution yeah
yeah
do you find that all the the basic
problems of everything we're talking
about here whether you're back home in
the UK or here that it basically is the
same that everything that the way we all
talk about the problems now has become
global
um right it feels like there's some
variety what I wonder is would I ask
myself would I be happier if I lived a
life of complete service would I be
happier is it working for me are the
systems working the systems of personal
gratification I've improved a lot I
don't live how I used to live
that's the question that I ask of myself
is are do things seem different in
different places I suppose so but there
does also seem to be a general sense
that is quite Global and I don't know
what it's like in Pakistan or Luxembourg
but like in the places that I go to and
know I feel like there is a hunger and
appetite and unease a sense of
atrophy and most cultures talk about
ages and epochs and identifiable periods
and Trends you know and of course
perhaps there's even a narcissism to
that because all of us are going to
experience Armageddon we are all going
to die and I do query sometimes Dave
whether it matters even in Florida even
in Florida I think be okay here
especially in Florida looking at some of
the demographic right like like I feel
that
perhaps there's a kind of a vanity to it
that you know does it matter if everyone
dies simultaneously or not if the planet
is going to ultimately expire but I do
believe in the sanctity of human life I
do believe in the unique beauty or or or
of our kind of our species and I do
believe in God and I do believe that
we're here to realize something valuable
and beautiful and that we should be
aspirational in our relationships with
one another and for me if it isn't as we
were discussing earlier today if it
isn't based in action like if your
experience of love and devotion in the
Divine doesn't have some expression in
your behavior then it's fantasy you have
parts of your life that you haven't kind
of put together yet yeah the whole thing
really I'm still trying to work it all
out I'm still trying to work it all out
but I I like I've recognized that when
I'm sort of I'm quite tired you know
today I'm a bit worn out and I'm a bit's
almost a little bit tearful but like I I
recognize that I have a facility for
language that could perhaps Master the
fact that I knowledge that I don't
really know what I'm doing I'm just
asking some questions I don't actually
think that anyone else knows what
they're doing either that's what I've
always thought when like in dealing with
sort of political demagogues like sort
of Boris Johnson or anybody no one knows
what do you know what does anybody know
I know there are you know like they're
people that are expert plumbers and
expert in construction and medicine and
all of that and that there are different
fields of expertise but all of this for
me leads to the smallest possible model
smallest possible business model
smallest possible uh Democratic models
most ability to organize your own life
possible not like that life becomes
abstract and your role is to sort of
stare at a screen and participate only
through consuming so you don't have any
role other than abstract expressions of
your own outrage yeah you know the the
famous quote by assortunits and uh all
that we have to in essence I'm going to
slightly butcher it but we just we went
through worse
but you know basically he said all we
have to do to end this is start
participating in the LIE and it seems
like everyone basically is participating
like even even accidentally and I mean
that for us guys that are responding to
stuff because it's out there and we're
trying to make sense of it for people or
for ourselves and yet we still have to
participate in a game that's that's
pretty dirty well that's what I have
been saying in these conversations uh
explicitly in the case of with Joe Rogan
and now I will say to you perhaps it
isn't enough for us to engage only in
punditry or even advocacy perhaps it has
to become all right then let's try and
build and like well I think that there
should be communities of like subgroups
of around I don't know is it a hundred
people that's what chimpanzees seem to
do well with that two percent of DNA's
got to afford or something maybe we can
run slightly larger communities right
what are the general principles what is
the amount of power you want to yield
how many ways are there of organizing
this how much can we leave one another
alone we are you know I perhaps yeah
perhaps we do need to be involved in a
new Confederacy in the building systems
that's why I built this thing I mean I
built this company we merged with Rumble
to to do exactly this at the digital
level I haven't Built My Own uh it'd be
good if you just met this side I meant
this side I put this together I built
this it's pretty nice right but this is
that sturdy come on that's a sturdy
sound very satisfying it's brilliant I
really like it well done I mean but but
also but that is what you mean right
like that we have to build new things
you don't just mean physical communities
you mean like we have to rebuild sort of
everything right yes
that doesn't work I know but like maybe
if we were all doing just our own little
bit yeah then it's sort of manageable
isn't it I mean again that's another
thing I get from recovery the idea that
we're all a bit mental and a bit broken
but not at the same time and it's nice
to be able to reach out sometimes I'm
having a bit of a like we can connect
not at the point of our posturing but at
the point of our vulnerability so I
actually like I don't know I don't know
what to do what do you think it seems
you're like no I had any experience once
where I I stopped to help a person who
had had a accident it wasn't a serious
accident she'd only bang the red a bit
in a car in the UK and I was sort of
helping you know like because I've
stopped because it's you know with human
Duty and lots of other people stopped
too and like it was an interesting
community that formed around that
accident and an off-duty paramedic
ultimately arrived at the scene and I
saw that in that instance that is the
person that you want in Authority yeah
but moments later someone else might be
required to to be in a position of
authority so I'm having intransigent
systems of power that are based on the
assumption that human beings need to be
marshaled compliantly into Community or
into behaving well I am at odds with and
you say libertarianism and as I
understand that that means individual
freedom and the most Freedom as an
individual whether that's the freedom of
to express your sexual identity
consensually or the freedom to express
whatever aspect of yourself that is and
uh and what I understand of anarchism
it's about the maximum amount of
democracy and the least amount of
dominion organization happening at the
level of community and the people that I
admire women like her Helen and Norbert
cardry for years has been advocating for
you should eat food that's grown where
you are yeah and you should people
should support local farming Enterprises
in Vandana Shiva who do not let
industrialized agriculture take over the
world like these are the kind of like
these voices
ought to be integrated Incorporated
amplify and these terms of left and
right I reckon we've got to let go of
them I mean I know that sort of part of
your narrative your story your life is
that you've transitioned from Liberal to
you know and you know I don't feel like
I'm saying anything different than I was
saying when I was a kid of like I I'm
anti-institution and the establishment
corruption and you know like these are
the things I'm saying people I think
last time I was here people thought I
was like a Marxist communist
conspiracy theorist I'm saying the same
thing it's kind of fun to keep people on
their toes though right like that's kind
of in its own way even though I don't
think you're doing it by Design right
next time I'll come back as a vampire
I'm a vampire now I'm Pinocchio yeah
yeah then you'll have a serious
political movement behind you I I could
see that
um what else is on your mind that you're
not doing publicly like nothing is it
like you're just like a canvas out there
and it's just kind of no like I live
like look the focus of my life is my
wife and my children and my meditation
and my recovery and Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
and meditate like and just trying to
hold together the ability to do what you
know like our jobs now yeah of like
broadcasting five days a week on Rumble
and creating that content and trying to
manage these complex arguments that can
easily become divisive incendry yeah it
ain't easy It Ain't Easy Dave mate is it
an alley because I feel like I really
need a week I think I think a wee moment
I think
how long has this been since yeah
started talking yeah it's been about an
hour I think yeah
I've never ended an interview with
someone having to go to the bathroom but
I feel that that's appropriate for this
is it all right yeah is there anything
else you want to talk about in terms of
your body
functions or yeah yeah oh I meant just
the personal side is there anything you
know
um no my bodily functions are also quite
good a general sense of weariness and
fatigue but also optimism about your
country and the potential of
conversations such as the ones we're
having to lead to new forms of Alliance
and an optimistic approach to politics
and culture can I just say one thing
before I let you pee and then I promise
you what if I just go I mean just I
guess it's very relaxed it would be but
I promise you it's a nice thing which is
that for me doing this whole thing and
talking about politics the way I do and
the culture wars and all of this stuff
and that I somehow decided to create a
company that then merged with the other
company and that one of the guys on the
short list of people that I think is
making sense in the world is sitting in
the room with me doing this right now
and all that like that's the thing
that's the other thing that's the
subtext between the other political
thing you're giving me that look that I
know means you got it so I think we're
good you're lovely Dave thank you right
if you're looking for more uncensored
opinions from today's thought leaders
check out our media playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a wide
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell